[Music]
[Music]
i can never be lord of winterfell
i can never be lord of anything and the
three i'd raven it means i can see
everything
bran stark the kid who tells everyone
throughout season seven and eight that
he cannot be a lord of anything because
he's the three-eyed raven now
is okay with becoming a king and most
people think bran is this
good guy who is the best choice to lead
westeros into a better future
bran who claims he is this powerful
three-eyed raven who can see everything
who can morgan to others and who can
travel throughout the time does
nothing throughout season 8 but what if
i tell you bran is the ultimate villain
of game of thrones
the ultimate evil who used his abilities
to orchestrate entire season 8.
made dany go mad allowed king's landing
and its 1 million people to burn alive
also he the three-eyed raven could end
up on the throne
season 8 episode 6 made it clear that
brain knew everything that would happen
but did not do anything to change it or
prevent it when tyrion asked bran if he
would accept to be their king braer
implies with
why do you think i came all the way here
later in the episode ben jon snow says
farewell to his
family john apologizes to bran for not
being there for him when he needed him
on which brain replied with you were
exactly where you were supposed to be
john terry on dany and the rest of the
characters were all chess pieces to him
that he used to get what he wants the
throne frank could have told dany not to
go to dragonstone back in episode 4
and warn her that yarn is there waiting
for her but he chose not to tell her
why because he knew danny was going to
lose another child
rhaegal and closest friend miss sande
and all of that matched with his plan
bray knew everything but chose to tell
only as much as it benefits his ultimate
goal
he manipulated things to turn exactly
how he saw it in season 8.
bran is the reason dan event mad queen
and he's the reason dany died
this was confirmed when bran told to
john you were exactly where you were
supposed to be
which is sad to me because danny
definitely did not deserve any of this
if not for dany all these starks
including jon as well would not be alive
at this point
if dany was not so good-hearted and if
she was this mad queen all along
she would not go north and help the
starks defend their ancestral home and
kingdom
but she did she helped them and saved
them she lost big portion of her armies
and friends in the process
and what did she get in return the
starks forming an ultimate plan how to
make her mad get her kill then win the
game of thrones
bran stark is the ultimate villain
littlefinger and varys were right when
they said knowledge is power
and the one with most knowledge bran
wins bran knows everything that's
happened
everything that's happening and
everything that will happen brand the
good honorable stark died in that cave
and became the three-eight raven
i'm not really you're a man
oh almost
not that person anymore you still would
be
if you hadn't pushed me out of that
window and i would still be brandon
stark
you're not no
i'm something else now
when benjen comes in out of nowhere and
rescues brain and mira
mira asks benjen why did he rescue them
he answered because the three-eyed raven
requested him
when mira counters that with saying that
the 3-8 raven just died benjen answered
he lives again
confirming that bran is the three-eyed
raven which bran confirmed himself over
and over again in season seven and eight
and the three i drive it why is this
important to highlight
well because every 3i raven that ever
existed and the current 3i raven as well
bran has the ability of green sight
which gives you power to perceive the
past present and future through visions
and time travel with ease bran already
had great power and could see future
before even becoming the 3 8 raven
of course not as clearly as he could
later on but still he had that power
remember back in season 2 bran had
strange dreams that he would talk about
with osha
this time he reveals a dream about the
sea flooding winterfell and drowning
winterfell and its people
even going as far to highlight sir roger
casella especially
indeed soon after that winterfell is
attacked by theon greyjoy and the
ironborn
roderick is captured and beheaded osha
then tells bran that his dream came true
the iron islands representing that the
sea in the dream have come to winterfell
with their drowned god to drown it
someone who also had the ability of
green sight was jojen reed
and he already knew how to see it
clearly in explaining the green side to
bran he tells him that there are visions
of past present and future
we see how clear jojen can see the
future when he brushes off the threads
to kill him off nice watch traitors
while being captured at craster's keep
saying he has already seen his death in
a vision and it will not be now
as he sees the vision of his hand on
fire indeed he died by fire when they
reach the 3i raymond's cape
why i'm telling you all of this is just
for you to understand that bran
who grew far more powerful than jojen
bran was definitely able to see
everything that was going to happen in
the future
he's seen it all play out before he did
bray knew the night king would come to
him and he knew arya would come and save
him
that's why he gave her valyrian steel
dagger bran started seeing glimpses
of past and future in season 4 something
which bran drastically improved over the
years
especially after becoming the 3 8 raven
bran saw drogon flying above king's
landing about to burn it down and even
saw aftermath of drogon and his burning
of king's landing
all of this he saw from his first vision
ever which was a long time ago
but he was not as powerful as he is now
years later this was much before he even
became the three-eyed raven
he also saw wildfire vision before
cersei blew the septobaler
not only is it safe to say but this is
an actual evidence supporting the fact
that bran knew what would happen to
king's landing before it actually
happened
but chose not to change anything and
chose 1 million people to die
also he could become the king everyone
from arya to jon were just puppets for
brain
and he used them to orchestrate the end
we've got brain orchestrated the deaths
of the night king as well as of dany
and ensured he would end up on the
throne bran is not bran stark anymore
bran died in that cave
when the old 38 raven transferred his
own mind to bran's he's the three-eyed
raven and his only goal was to end up on
the iron throne through the power of
seeing past
present and future to orchestrating
future events which he did by carefully
choosing what to say and what not to say
the night king was not coming after all
humanity he was coming for the 3 8 raven
which brent confirmed in season 8
episode 3.
the night king made them all they follow
his command
if he falls
getting to him may be our best chance if
that's true he'll never expose himself
yes he will he'll come for me
he's tried before many times with many
three-eyed ravens
bran says he is coming for him because
he is world's memory
and the night king wants to erase
world's memory but i am convinced the
night king was coming for this
three-eyed raven
to save the humanity from such a great
evil taking over
but he failed the first future event
bran orchestrated was the fall of the
night king by giving gary the valyrian
steel dagger
which he knew arya would later use to
kill the night king in that very same
spot
in the game of thrones among the living
though bran was as useless as he could
get
but he actually wasn't it's the fact
that bran can see the future and
manipulate it
bran's visions prove it the ending
proves it and bran confirms it by saying
why do you think i came all this way
to tirion when he asks him if he will be
their king
but let's imagine bran cannot see the
future and those glimpses of the future
that he can see
and what he saw truly only glimpses and
he cannot use them to tell what's going
to happen
which definitely is not because he kind
of confirmed he can see and orchestrate
the future by giving guardia the
valyrian steel dagger
on the same place that would later be
used to kill the night king and by
telling tyrion that he knew he would be
chosen a king
and by telling jon that he was exactly
where he was supposed to be
david benioff also said that bran said
thank you to theon because bran knew
what was going to happen
kind of confirming that bran has seen
everything and knows everything that's
going to happen in the future
but for the sake of the argument let's
say that's true let's say bran cannot
see and orchestrate the future
it still doesn't change the fact that he
could have prevented the burning of
king's landing
bran said it himself that he can see
everything that's happened and
everything that is happening
i can never be lord of winterfell
i can never be lord of anything and
three i'd raven
i don't know what that means it's
difficult to explain
try please for me
it means i can see everything
everything that's ever happened to
everyone everything that's happening
right now
it's all pieces now fragments
so why didn't he work into danny or
drogon and stop that madness
and prevent 1 million people from dying
or why didn't he warn dany that urine is
waiting for her at dragonstone
preventing him from killing danish
dragon and best friend he was there at
the war council just before she went to
dragonstone
oh yes i forgot it all had to happen it
was in fact orchestrated by bran so he
could get the throne
brent has been manipulating events
throughout the entire season eight that
would get him to this point
bran is the final villain of the story
bran manipulated sam into telling john
the truth
specifically after dany had just told
sam she'd burn his
father and brother alive it's time to
tell john the truth
you're his brother shouldn't you tell
him
i'm not his brother he trusts you more
than anyone
now's the time brand did this on purpose
knowing sam would not only reveal to jon
the truth
but also to tell jon that she is not the
best choice for the people of westeros
but more importantly bran knew jon would
not continue his relationship with dany
after finding out the truth
and then he would become more paranoid
after learning jon has the best claim to
the throne
and let's face it that's the only reason
jon found out the truth about his
parents rhaegar and lyanna
only so jon would end his relationship
with dany and would not give dany
affection she needed after losing her
children
her armies and her advisors the only
thing it would give dany is paranoia
bren also knew that jon was going to
tell the truth to his family arya and
sansa
and brand new stanza did not like dany
as she's littlefinger student
he knows sansa would start scheming
toward throw dany by using jon's claim
and he knew that this way the truth
behind josh's true parentage and claim
would spread
bran tells to sam to tell the truth to
jon jon tells the truth to his family
sensa tells it to tyrion therian tells
it to vary some various informs sold the
seven kingdoms
the truth spreads then his own advisors
start plotting behind her back
which makes dany grow more and more
paranoid bran intentionally doesn't warn
danny how urine is waiting for her at
dragonstone
even though he can see everything which
leads to dany losing rhaegal and
missandei
all of this making dany more frustrated
and ultimately turning her mad
which leads to her burning the entire
city and all the innocent
john is then left with no choice but to
kill her and jon himself must be
punished for this
also that scene where jaime asked bran
why didn't he tell everyone else what he
did to him on which bran replied
he would not be able to help us in this
fight if i let them murder you first
why didn't you tell them you won't be
able to help us in this fight if i let
them murder you first
jaime did not do anything of great
importance in the battle for winterfell
he did not have any role in killing the
night king he did not kill any white
walkers which would reduce the night
king's army during the battle
all he did was fighting whites like
everyone else in the living army
so he did not help at all during this
fight at least not more than any other
soldier
however he did something significant in
the other fight
the fight for king's landing when he
rang the hell bells that for some reason
made dany go crazy
so that must have been the hell bran saw
jaime would provide in the future
also seemingly seeing that after this he
would be killed by bricks
what about afterwards how do you know
there isn't afterwards
all the events bran manipulated led to
the outcome he's been working on this
entire season
bran stark becomes the king bran the one
with the most knowledge and does the
most
power wins the game of thrones he was
behind everything that happened in
season 8.
not so bad of an ending after all if it
was well written
and if bran had any other line then i
don't want anything really
i can't beat the lord of mine fell i'm
the three-eyed raven now and if the
execution was not so terrible
and if only they did not make dany go
from the ultimate savior to the ultimate
mad queen in the span of one episode
in fact it's how george armand's books
will end as well as they said multiple
times that the ending will be the same
but the journey to get there will be
quite different and the journey is
exactly what was so disappointing here
in the books we already have clues that
bran that create raven is evil
one of the visions melisandre sees in
the flames is about
a wooden face corpse white with a
thousand red eyes accompanied by a boy
with a wolf's face
and mel sanjay wonders if this is the
enemy her vision is obviously about the
old 38 raven teaching bran how to become
him
and she seems to think they are the real
enemy anyways dany going mad
bran becoming the king and everything
else could have been written so that all
of this would make sense
more importantly it should not have been
rushed there should have been more
episodes and more seasons to wrap it all
up nicely
even hbo knew it and offered dan and
david unlimited budget to do
10 seasons which they refused
why is it ending i don't know ask dave
and dan when they come through
um we could have gone to 11 12
13 seasons but uh they david and dan
um have been saying for yeah like five
years that
seven seasons was all they would go and
we got them to go to eight
but uh not any more than that so
uh yeah i had a custom a custom that
there was a period like five years ago
where they were saying
seven seasons and i was saying ten
seasons instead we got rushed and poorly
written season where the ending is
nowhere near bittersweet
only better bran did learn how to see
things better
and what did he choose to do with the
information he chose to sit in his
wheelchair
sacrifice everyone else orchestrate
things and events to lead him and his
family into ultimate victory
in the game of thrones they chose an
evil man to be their king
a guy who manipulated the entire plot
just to be a king
why do you think i came all this way
disgusts me it disgusts me that he knew
it all along
what a great king westeros has right now
a king that did not care to stop danny
from burning down king's landing and
killing one million people
brian manipulated the events to make
dany mad so jon would be forced to kill
her
this way dany is obviously dead and
cannot be the queen while jon takes the
black for killing her which makes him no
longer a legitimate heir to the throne
only after this bren decided to reveal
that he knew and saw all this play out
already
as he orchestrated all by telling some
little but more importantly not telling
more
bran basically used his all-seeing
ability of past present and future to
help only him and his family
not including jon snow because as he
said himself he does not see jon as his
brother
ensuring his family comes at the top at
the end instead of using it all for the
benefit of others to save others
if you ask me that makes bran stark the
ultimate villain of game of thrones
no human rules the six kingdoms the
three-eyed raven does
you're a man almost
what happened to you beyond the wall
i became the three-eyed raven the final
episode of game of thrones brands two
responses
firstly to tyrion when asked if he would
like to be their king
why do you think i came all this way and
second to john when john apologized for
not being there for him
you were exactly where you were supposed
to be proved he saw everything and
orchestrated everything
he is the reason king's landing burned
down his reason dany lost everything and
turned mad
also jon would have to kill her
eliminating them both from the iron
throne and taking it for himself
bran stark the three-eyed raven is the
ultimate villain of game of thrones
you